Zoomers think Ben Laden had a point why
are you
surprised I wouldn't say that I had a
happy childhood certainly not by modern
Western standards there were no fun play
groups after school sports clubs
Halloween parties fancy dress events or
movie Nights most of my pre-teen years
were spent doing what a lot of Soviet
kids of my generation did hanging around
the kitchen table listening to adult's
talk hang around the dining room
listening to adult's talk hanging around
the living room you get the point and
when my parents or grandparents
apartment wasn't filled with their adult
friends and relatives they would often
talk to me and tell me stories As I Grew
Older the stories went from the usual
fairy tales to being stories of our past
these were not fun stories they were not
inspiring they were not uplifting happy
endings were conspicuous by their
absence as a kid I couldn't understand
why adults would spend their time
retelling and reliving these horrible
events that they were telling me about
why did did my grandmother tell me about
watching her baby brother starve to
death after the Communists kicked them
out of their house for being kolac rich
peasants accused affording grain and
supplies why did my father's stepmother
tell me about being born in a gulag why
did she tell me about the gulag Gods
many of whom shot themselves when Stalin
died and was denounced by the party who
were suddenly forced to confront the
reality that rather than doing good they
had in fact been complicit in his crimes
you might be asking the same question
why aren't children supposed to have fun
aren't we all supposed to have fun isn't
that what life is about pleasure joy and
above all fun why inflict such
nightmarish realities on the fragile
Mind of a child who lives in a different
world and will never face the terrible
realities of the past why should our
children read the gag archipelago
everything flows or watch Schindler's
List they're not exactly fun it was only
much much later when I saw what was
happening in the west with my own eyes
that I understood the why we teach our
children about the tragic realities of
the past Because unless we do they will
repeat them this is what allw well meant
when he said that he who controls the
past controls the future and he who
controls the present controls the past
this is why I'm surprised that anyone is
surprised by the recent Revelations that
Tik Tok Zoomers have discovered Osama
Bin Laden's letter to America and it
opened their eyes to the evils of the US
how are you surprised by this what did
you think was happening why did you
think so many of us who have seen all
this play out before have been warning
you so loudly about it you have to
understand the consequences of the
things that you understand you
understand that our children are not
being taught history objectively they're
being taught to view their own
civilization and its values as wrong
immoral and uniquely evil what did you
think the consequences of this would be
you understand that our children are not
being taught the Martin Luther King
dream of people being treated on the the
content of their character they're being
Tau that some people are more equal than
others few of them could reliably
identify where that quote even comes
from they haven't read Animal Farm they
have not been inoculated against the
Marxist disease on the contrary a new
and improved version of the Marxist
disease has been force fed down their
throats by their teachers and lecturers
why would you expect them not to succumb
to it you understand that they have been
given a single lens through which to
view every interaction every conflict
every war in any situation the first
question is who is the oppressor and who
is the oppressed like a teacher who is
late to a fight in the playground all
they see is that whoever is losing the
fight is the victim and whoever is
winning the fight is the bully as long
as the West is strong they will be
predisposed to hating it they don't
understand that they'll be the ones that
suffer most when Pax Americana ends you
understand that not only is this
generation even more historically eant
than my own it is also extraordinary
arily lucky they grew up in a world
without existential threats so did their
parents in many cases so did their
grandparents they have neither the
historical context nor the personal
experience to give them a grounding in
how the real world Works schools
colleges universities the media and most
of all their parents have failed to
prepare this generation not just to
defend their own civilization but to
even know why it's worth defending why
are you surprised that they're morally
unprepared for this moment before you go
couple of quick things first of all
these videos are based on articles I
write on my substack if you want to get
them first get Early Access by
subscribing now secondly let me take a
minute to recommend a longevity
supplement by Verso in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David Sinclair have recently
made some fascinating discoveries on how
to mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that is why I'm using ver
Vero Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products that I take
every day is cell beinging cell beinging
helps combat aging by increasing
something called NAD Plus in your body
now NAD is arguably the most important
molecule in your body high NAD levels
improve your metabolism repair damage
DNA and increase energy production in
your brain immune system and muscles but
as you grow old your body's NAD levels
go down and you can't take NAD as a
supplement because it's too big for your
cells to absorb that's why versus Cell
being contains nmn Resveratrol and TMG
these three molecules work together to
increase your NAD plus levels if you
want to read more about this check out
the scientific research Linked In the
description of this video plus Verso
publishes third- party testing on every
batch of its products to guarantee that
you're getting exactly what you're
paying for so if you want to join me you
can get 15% of going to
v.o that's
v.o and use our code trigger to say 15%
off your order by the way if you enjoyed
this video make sure to check out the
one I did about how terrible ideas take
over Society where I explain why the
world makes less and less sense every
day